[Musica]
Direi che ho già fatto rumore
Ciao a tutti io sono Dada
[Applauso]
e sono una cantautrice napoletana
Diciamo che in questa occasione ho
cercato un po' cosa significasse il
rumore in generale ma non ho trovato
nulla che rispecchiasse il mio rapporto
con il rumore quindi ho abbandonato
qualsiasi definizione e sono partita da
me per definizione il rumore è un
segnale indesiderato di disturbo Wow E
cosa ci ha fatto questo rumore ho
pensato e quindi ho scoperto che il
rumore
diciamo può essere qualcosa di positivo
ma anche di negativo
basato anche sulla mia esperienza
personale
mi chiamo Gaia Gaia Eleonora Cipollaro
mia mamma mi ha chiamato Gaia e il mio
disordine Diciamo che dico che colpa sua
l'ha voluto lei perché nella mitologia
Gaia Gea la terra nasce dal caos Quindi
se sono disordinata è colpa sua
però ho capito anche crescendo che tutti
quanti Forse siamo un po' animati da due
forze No dal caos Quindi questa materia
incontrollata magmatica che cerca di
uscire in qualche modo e da Cosmos
l'ordine la materia si raffredda può
essere toccato e noi cerchiamo di
controllarla così ho scoperto che la
natura non è così perfettina diciamo
come sembra ma è anche aggrovigliata
e casinista
ho scoperto che esiste una frequenza
impercettibile e che il silenzio non
esiste questa frequenza diciamo è 50
Hertz alcuni l'hanno resa percepibile
diciamo all'orecchio e hanno composto
anche delle canzoni Esiste la Noise
Music a partire da Lou Reed come
cantautrice però non ho voluto diciamo
fare musica con i rumori ma portarvi
altrove forse anche un po' nella mia
storia personale io nasco a Napoli dove
di rumori Ce ne sono tantissimi ma anche
il sud è pieno di rumori tipo
Dominick
sicuramente l'avete sentito anche voi no
qui e quindi tutti questi rumori Mi
hanno ispirato anche nello scrivere
canzoni da piccolo Ho cercato nella voce
delle cose Quindi nei rumori la mia voce
ed ero solita tamburellare con le dita
sui bicchieri a tavola e mi diceva
Magari assai ferma sui denti
così gaia stai ferma diventi sdentata
finalmente Poi mi hanno dato una
chitarra e ho potuto trasformare questi
rumori nei miei suoni
scrivo le prime canzoni in silenzio a
casa della nonna anche forse un po' per
vergogna di far sentire diciamo la mia
voce per l'imbarazzo
questa piccola pennellata diciamo
giocosa che voglio tracciare con noi con
voi parte anche dalla dall'asilo
quando ero piccola sono stata dalle
suore penso che si veda
e mi facevano fare sempre un gioco che
all'epoca reputavo veramente strano poi
ho capito che la buona anima di suor
Franca sapeva che sarei venuta qui da
voi e quindi mi ha insegnato questo
gioco che vorrei provare a fare con voi
se mi aiutate e partecipate Anche perché
è tutto registrato voglio far vedere il
video alla nonna è già stato difficile
spiegare Chi è Ted Quindi se partecipate
magari ce la facciamo magari sulle sedie
facciamo tre movimenti con le unghie
la pioggia
questo le suore me l'hanno insegnato
quindi
così la grandine io non voglio sfondare
il microfono Ok
e se ce la fate se proprio siete in vena
con i piedi i tuoni
e proviamo magari insieme a ricreare un
piccolo temporale Mettetevi tanta grinta
quindi un po' di pioggia
grandine
e tuoni
questa cosa ce la facciamo fare le suore
non so perché probabilmente per
rinfrescarci diciamo no un po' Però
appena mi hanno parlato del rumore a me
è venuto in mente Da piccola mi
divertivo tantissimo nel farlo e
passavamo le ore probabilmente era
semplicemente per tenerci buono Buoni
però è una cosa che mi è piaciuta
tantissimo Quindi ho capito che ci
orientiamo tra i rumori il rumore
richiama All'attenzione alla
disponibilità chiamiamo il cagnolino
agitiamo il pacchetto di crocchette
oppure il bimbo è in culla e il
sonaglietto la meditazione Zen il rumore
del mare i rumori alla fine ci servono e
siamo anche abituati ai rumori volete
vedere mi giro cerco di farvi sentire
dei rumori
e voi Indovinate che Rumori sono spiate
Che cos'è
facilissimo
quest'altro
cosa
forbici Quindi ho capito che in realtà
noi li riconosciamo e ne abbiamo bisogno
Certo alcuni sono veramente fastidiosi
Ho saputo che alcune persone si
rilassano ascoltando il rumore del phon
perché dovrebbe ricreare il suono che il
bimbo Ascolta in grembo grazie alla
placenta i liquidi eccetera e poi ho
scoperto che ci sono persone che odiano
Il Fischietto quando il treno sta per
partire quella persona sono io e volevo
soltanto uno spazio per denunciare
questa cosa Gentilmente quando fischiate
quando il treno parte un po' più piano
quindi ho scoperto anche che c'è una
tolleranza soggettiva ai rumori No a me
può piacere un rumore a te un altro e ho
capito che si accetto il mio rumore
accetto anche quello dell'altro e
viceversa quindi niente grassi di cose
Poi scoperto che in altre lingue il
rumore viene rappresentato ovviamente
culturalmente in maniera diversa Ho
scoperto che i giapponesi per indicare
il rumore quindi la voce delle cose
utilizzano un kanji una diciamo
costruzione grafica che spesso viene
anche rappresentata con tre donne che
parlano quindi tre donne che parlano
producono rumore Mo io ho pensato da
napoletano se tre vecchiette che stanno
inciuciando sapessero che i giapponesi
per dire rumore utilizzano numero 3 che
parlano penso che l'unico rumore che si
sentirebbe sarebbe quello della scopa
sul culo del giapponese
E ho anche mi sono anche ricordata che
in inglese rumors vuol dire
chiacchiericcio pettegolezzo quindi io
stasera voglio concludere semplicemente
questa introduzione un po' giocosa con
un brano che è uscito stanotte che ho
scritto a 17 anni Ma che adesso diciamo
Eseguo per la prima volta quindi sono
anche molto emozionata e questo brano
parla proprio dei pettegolezzi parla di
leonilda una vecchietta realmente
esistita che abitava di fronte il basso
della mia nonna e in questo vicoletto
stretto tu e quanti rumori che c'erano e
tra tutti questi rumori c'erano
sicuramente gli inciuci del quartiere
che proverò a raccontarvi in musica
Napoli diciamo a una lingua molto simile
Comunque anche al dialetto molto simile
anche al vostro quindi spero che
riuscirete a farvi un po' i fatti di
questo vicariello grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
più comodo del mondo ce l'ho io
[Musica]
mezza giornata
avviene lo sportello una sei sposata
che bella casa
attrezzature
con ma sopra
la spazzola lecca la lingua facciano un
pesce
sembra che è stato per te normale la
fate fiuto un Pascale siamo chiare pure
sparlare
un carnevale pensa e creature va'
faticare Mannaggia a morte puzza
Ra allerta allerta
Leonida con mamma assomiglia due a chi
sei figlio adotti ce leonista non
importa
tu a chi si è impigliato dice leoni il
tè
Maccio magnata
Guarda me lo ortello così ci scuso sul
latte che Recchia pizzata
sino con messapizzato tutte fatte
essi se è passata però mostrato fermo tu
poi siamo ammaccata
[Musica]
solette depressa
tu a chi si fischiato dice leoni il tè
umiltà con mamma assomiglia tu a chi si
è fischiato dice leonista
non so come niente però
[Musica]
come mutande
soletta però
[Musica]
tutta quanta mo' canzone
però
ingiungere
[Musica]
tutta quanta
Grazie
[Applauso]